voilà pour cette conférence de presse du
secrétaire américain à la défense lloyd
austin
qui
est déterminé à faire davantage pour
l'ukraine at il déclaré il faut
renforcer le système militaire sur le
long terme rassembler les bonnes
volontés d'ailleurs les alliés des
américains se rencontreront tous les
mois pour faire le point on n'a pas
appris grand-chose gauthier rybinski
suite à cette conférence de presse mais
on voit bien que les américains là sont
à la manoeuvre on le leadership
sur sur les armes oui c'est peut-être ça
vous avez raison l'essentiel de ce genre
de non seulement de conférence mais
surtout deux rencontres en amont dans la
mesure où vous avez bien remarqué que
jusqu'ici c'est la russie qui impose qui
a une sorte de magistère rhétorique
c'est la russie qui tient des propos
plus qu'audacieux sur l'éventualité
d'une troisième guerre mondiale c'est la
russie qui dénonce l'armement de
l'ukraine bref à chaque fois on a le
sentiment que l'occident et l'europe en
premier lieu sont un peu timides et
prennent des coups avant de riposter
là effectivement il y a une manière de
faire comprendre que cette machine dead
enfin efficiente à l'ukraine est en
marche et que avec la livraison de
d'armes lourdes comme celles auxquelles
pensent les américains et celles qui
sont ceux de l'allemagne de la pologne
et également de la france que cela
aurait un effet capital sur le l'issue
de la guerre il ya peut-être un biais
qui peut être dangereux c'est que au
fond les américains sont persuadés que
les ukrainiens s'ils sont bien armés
peuvent s'en sortir c'est pas sûr du
tout mais ça peut être une façon de se
laver les mains de la question disant
écoutez nous on a fait le mieux 6e
ukrainiens ne sont pas capables de
vaincre pourtant leur a donné tous les
moyens c'est un peu spéciaux et ça peut
être à double tranchant cette attitude
parce que aussi bien l aide actuellement
les ukrainiens mais elle est aussi une
façon de dire si ça ne tourne pas en
faveur des ukrainiens nous on pourra
s'en sortir les mains donc qui ne
croient pas en
une sortie de crise diplomatique
c'est à dire que ce qui ce que dit lloyd
austin et est important lorsqu'il
souligne qu'il faut terminer le conflit
terminé le conflit si on veut vraiment
le terminer ça veut dire terminer le
conflit avec une victoire ukrainienne et
puis après voir ce que ça peut donner
sur le régime de poutine s'est
véritablement ça l'objectif politique
victoire militaire une victoire
militaire et une victoire aussi pour
secouer ce régime c'est ce que disait
joe biden qui effectivement lui
reprochant le dividende est commis une
bourde en disant qu' il fallait qu'il
fallait démonter vladimir poutine mais
c'est effectivement ça alors quand on a
le disco qui consiste à dire terminons
la guerre au plus vite possible ça peut
très bien vouloir dire qu' il faudrait
que les ukrainiens soit battu vous voyez
ça n'est pas aussi
univoque que ça devrait l'être il y a
certes ce mouvement qui consiste à armer
correctement les ukrainiens c'est à dire
comme il le souhaite depuis à peu près
oui vous avez dit 62 jours bon on va
dire un petit peu moins depuis cinquante
mais de toute manière la question est
vraiment là c'est à dire de faire en
sorte que ces armes puissent servir non
seulement à donner un élan
à l'ukraine sur le plan militaire mais
également que la communauté
internationale soit persuadé qu'il n'y a
rien qui puisse changer la donne tant
que vladimir poutine sera au pouvoir je
ne dis pas que c'est facile je n'ai pas
ce que ça va se passer et
fondamentalement la seule véritable
issue de ce conflit c'est celle là c'est
à dire de mettre à bas une dictature ni
plus ni moins et ne pas apparaître comme
co belligérants ça c'est ce que à dire
ça gagne lavrov finalement il a
il a dit qu'il y avait un risque réel de
troisième guerre mondiale oui alors
c'est une menace je ne sais pas s'il se
fonder exactement sur cette comédie
gérant cela qui consiste certes à
fournir des armes mais à ne pas
intervenir directement puisqu'on a
toujours dit que c'était ça la limite de
coke belligérance intervention de l'otan
ou pas et fournitures dame si la russie
repousse cette notion de co belligérance
à l'importation à l'acheminement de
matériel militaire pour l'ukraine c'est
effectivement une nouvelle ligne rouge
qui bouge est ce que l'europe et
l'occident doivent laisser à nouveau la
russie fixer les nuits rouges n'ont sans
doute que non mais là où il y a un
empêchement pour pour les fournitures
pour les acheminements d'armes c'est
effectivement à partir du moment où ces
armes sont sur le territoire ukrainien
évidemment qu'elles sont susceptibles
d'être visés et bombardée par la russie
si la russie arrive je souligne
simplement un fait élémentaire c'est que
jusqu'à présent il s'agissait d'armes
légères qui peuvent passer entre
guillemets inaperçu mais lorsqu'il
s'agit de 200 chars par exemple comme ce
que propose l'allemagne évidemment ça ne
passe pas l'allemagne d'un mot gaultier
pour la première fois elle annonce la
livraison de blindés guépards et léopard
c'est un gros revirement ça divise la
coalition pas forcément mais c'est un
revirement c'est une révolution
copernicienne pour l'allemagne qui n'a
jamais livré de matériel depuis la
deuxième guerre mondiale mondiale et qui
surtout se faisait une fierté de naître
impliqué dans aucun des conflits ne
veulent pas le rester sur la touche elle
voulait pas rester sur la touche parce
qu'on lui a beaucoup reproché parce
qu'indépendamment de ça on dit toujours
à l'allemagne vous êtes un géant
économique parce que vous faites des
économies sur le budget militaire
que donc vous vous profitez des autres
pots assurer votre sécurité donc là
aussi il y avait un reproche et puis il
ya surtout à il y avait surtout à
combattre enfin à aller à l'encontre de
l'opinion publique allemande est là
aussi revirement d'importance
aujourd'hui dans tous les sondages en
allemagne l'opinion publique se portent
volontairement et de manière délibérée
se prononce pour une des fournitures
délais et d un approvisionnement en
armes de l'ukraine on verra le jour où
l'allemagne dépendant énormément du gaz
russe il y à des pénuries en allemagne
peut-être que l'opinion publique
changera d'avis mais enfin pour
l'instant elle aussi a fait sa
révolution copernicienne un changement
de pied merci beaucoup gauthier merci à
vous d'avoir suivi cette nouvelle
édition spéciale on se retrouve dans 5
minutes pour le journal de 17h30
[Musique]